[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the aforementioned sean white 35 years
of age turning 36 coming up in september
growing up right before our very eyes
and i believe officially retired
back from the olympics finishing fourth
in the half pipe and sean uh joins us
now are you officially retired
i am yeah which is so wild to say i'm
35. you know i guess older in the sport
of snowboarding but i still feel like i
got
a lot to look forward to yeah but you're
35 brady just retired at 44 sean i mean
yeah yeah i mean i i guess
you know when i think about it if you're
throwing the ball and you're off a few
inches or so it's it's not as as bad as
when you're 20 feet in the air looking
at this
isn't good
[Laughter]
what is that feeling like though when
you're getting some big air
and you know that this might hurt
oh yeah it's like the scene in talladega
nights where he's like oh i'm flying
through here
you know like everything slows down and
you're just like oh my goodness it's
kind of like when you you hit a ball or
you you know you you do that shot and
you just know you messed up right away
so you have all that time in the air to
think about wow okay do i want to land
on my back
do i want to
why did i get into this situation in the
first place uh so yeah it's not good do
you teach yourself how to fall how to
land
no but there is art to it i would say
because a lot of people they just panic
and i kind of like assess the situation
and go okay well there's kind of like a
way to roll out of it and slide or
something um
but you know it is a it happens you're
gonna crash just like anything you there
will be mistakes and you you know you
gotta kind of like roll with those
injuries and learn from them we were
wondering if you've ever held a job
a job yeah so let's go around the room
here who believes other than
snowboarding or skateboarding has do you
believe that sean white has held a
regular job todd i think he has i think
he may have dabbled in like a little
something with children like a little
camp counselor things from the side
little summer camp okay to help the kids
with skateboarding paulie i want to say
yeah brief pizza delivery at a young age
on a bicycle okay uh seton look at a
very young age paper route paper does
that count okay
sean have you held an actual job
[Laughter]
[Applause]
snowboard i mean i was sponsored at
seven so
it was pretty much what are you making
age seven how much money are you making
at age seven well yeah i was amateur so
i was of course you were i would just
had travel budget and whatnot which was
pretty wild um but uh i started making
money when i was probably 14
and i i got my first i guess i don't
know
i didn't even know what this meant at
the time my mom's like it's a million
dollar deal it's like
okay
well i guess that's good we won that now
what you know like i didn't really just
like a number and i had everything i
ever wanted which was skateboards and
snowboards so how did million dollars
change your life
um at the time not much i mean i was
just so thrilled i mean once i turned
you know uh 16 17 i could get a car that
was pretty cool um
and then um you know i i invested my mom
got me into like real estate because i
think they were worried about the car
and the cars that might come so
it kind of tied a lot of my finances up
but honestly it was it was quite a
burden in the beginning because
you know it's fabulous to make it you
know and then it's just like what do you
do and it's not something i really
learned in school um
and people do go to school to learn
exactly how to invest and do these
things and so that was kind of like a a
hard thing to learn but um
but yeah i mean it gave me that comfort
i guess of saying like wow at least
it all falls away you know through this
snowboarding i was able to put a roof
over my head and that's that's you know
fantastic so that was kind of that why i
ended up getting a home when i was so
young
what role did tony hawk play in your
career
yeah tony hawk i mean he basically
you know was my hero and every kid my
age was just fascinated with him and um
he would skate my local skate park and i
just assumed one day i had this grand
plan in my head that if i just skated
well enough he might come talk to me so
i was too terrified to approach him and
uh
it worked i skated and i did new tricks
every day and he strolled by and invited
me to go to the skateboarding demo with
him which sparked this friendship and um
you know he never really sat me down and
gave me specific advice but he was the
only one that i knew that was going
through everything i was about to go
through he had his video game people
knew his name everywhere and you know
but he was still a family man and um i
got to just watch him interact with fans
how he divided his time with his family
and things and and he really remained
the same guy through all of it uh the
success and the ups and downs and so he
was just like that that perfect person
to be around when he fills out his taxes
i said what do you put down and he said
skateboarder
he does
i bet
you don't put what do you put down as
your occupation
i guess i'd say athlete
but yeah
snowboarder would probably nowadays they
might be like oh okay yeah that's pretty
cool i saw where uh some athletes
reached out to you former ones david
beckham tom brady yeah pretty pretty
cool uh territory yeah i was getting
these funny emails of like your
application has been accepted to the tom
brady michael jordan michael phelps uh
david beckham retirement home
nice
oh no so cool i mean
amazing talents and legends in their
sports and um to kind of have them
cheering me on and having followed my
career and uh
i mean it's just so great the respect
among athletes and i'm so
pleased to call them friends you know
and um
and it's exciting to to look at their
careers and what they still mean to
their sport even though they haven't
been competitive in some time you know
it's it's it's definitely a weird
territory new waters for me you know i'm
so used to like
getting out there and earning my
my cred and to finally be putting that
to rest and you know enjoy what i have
accomplished already and to see those
those messages really you know
solidifies a lot of that from me inside
so that was really nice he's retired now
sean white he placed fourth in the
halfpipe snowboarding competition in
beijing and then you left beijing that
you wanted to attend the super bowl
yeah well i i had my my girlfriend sat
you know she's like she should be i was
like i got so much stuff i want to do
when i have the time for it you gotta
make a list and like third on the list
was like go to the super bowl i've never
been there's always some competition or
something that's kept me from attending
and uh
and boom i'm flying home from china i
land like family's there to meet me i
said hi to everyone and then i rushed
off to the super bowl and it was just
amazing the rams won
which was so cool um having spent so
much time in la
but yeah it's like all those little
things i get to do now i'm very excited
about what what was number one and
number two on the list
i'm trying to remember uh i think it was
just places to travel to somewhere warm
you know so much time in the cold
what about getting engaged where is it
getting engaged on your list of things
to do yeah it's in there somewhere
you know it's it's it's so nice to
finally have the time to spend with
somebody you know and uh i am in an
amazing relationship so we'll see where
it goes but i know my my brother and
sister
um have children and uh you know that
the thought of that was so i pushed it
off for so long
um
you know but then once your you know
siblings have their own kids and you're
in the mix and just family's so
important to me i'm sure it's something
i definitely
want to experience in my life so we'll
see well you're grown up now you got to
do big boy things now you're 35 you got
no excuses
[Music]
she put you up to this uh no i no but i
i i saw on social media and it's like
yeah okay so
you know just so you know that uh
shawn's girlfriend nina dobrev is an
actress and she put some pictures i
guess in your travel bag so
yeah and i mean people couldn't no one
was allowed to attend the olympics and
it was so hard because every time
normally i have family friends you know
support group and um and no one was
there this time it was just myself coach
and actually a physical therapist named
esther who's just incredible um that was
along for this this ride and she got a
medical credential to go
um but yeah i opened up my bags and they
were just pictures of
our relationship together and
friends uh and family pictures with
notes and all these things that i kept
finding and then made this incredible
video of people wishing me um you know
the best of luck and what i mean to them
and uh you know just the years you
forget how many years you've been doing
something and how it's kind of like the
ripple effect of everyone and they're
like all right like we finally get you
home we get you back we'll get you on
time with you obviously it's wonderful
winning these awards but we like to
spend time with you just you know
doing normal things so it's nice to
kind of see all that but yeah she's been
so monumental in this whole
transitioning period for me um and
showing me what
that other life looks like so it's great
you have your final run and
you know you couldn't help be moved
watching you be emotional there
get kind of
like like have you seen yourself
uh after you've had that run and how
emotional you were
i've watched a bit of it yeah i i can't
watch it without getting emotional um
you know you you
i guess i i was told when i was a kid
that this day would come and hey it's
the inevitable you'll get to a point
where you either can't ride or the
tricks get too heavy or you something
some sign will happen and you'll retire
and um just to be
actually living that moment that
i'd heard about and never really thought
about until it really happened and um
yeah it was moving and a lot of the
competitors had lined up at the bottom
and came and gave me a hug and told me
what it meant to them that i was there
competing with them and what i've meant
to them for their careers and i mean one
of the guys
was like i haven't told you this ever
but i
my first board i had your pro model
board i wore your the jacket you wore i
wanted to beat you
so wild you know and um
and then they pulled up my family on the
big screen they had a big big tv there
and just to see their faces and
realize you know we've all been in this
kind of journey together for so long in
a sport that was very misunderstood you
know um
snowboarding had no olympics it had the
x games had barely even started it was
very like we were kind of throwing our
lives away
in people's opinions by you know putting
so much into this sport um but i just
believed and i knew
that at the end of the day i enjoyed it
so much that who cares
but it turned into this amazing thing
and just to see where it's come from and
how big of a part i've played in that um
was just wild so i got very emotional
like i don't think i've cried as much
oh i didn't olympics before and i got
emotional watching the deer rider
documentary
at the at the very end
when you guys are doing the ceremonial
basically goodbye
with jake burton and uh i mean and his
wife and watching that with his uh with
her kids and
that that was pretty impactful there
yeah heavy you know like
really the father of our sport and his
passing was just so heartbreaking for a
lot of us you know and um and it
happened very suddenly so i know he had
his certain health problems throughout
his life but you know this one came so
quickly and so abruptly
and
you know just remembering him and and
that was something i even mentioned in
one of my interviews out there just like
it's so bizarre to get to the bottom
because i've seen him after every
olympics you know and taken our photo
together
and you know i think he would have been
proud
um
on how how everything ended and
um
you know it's just it's just wild to see
how much
the sport has changed they used to dig
those happenings with shovels
now
to look at the the the you know mind
this it's huge it's 22 foot walls i mean
i don't think the tv really puts it into
perspective you know the scale of it all
you know um but just to see where it's
come is just incredible go get a job
sean okay
yeah
i did want to have a i did want to have
a summer job at like uh
i wanted to go to in-n-out burger and
work the counter and just kind of give
people a hard time when they came
through
you know what you should do is get a
documentary crew and just yeah all these
jobs that you thought about doing and
just do one shift
yeah yeah i like that that's not bad
just go into in and out and you're there
taking orders
getting it done yeah go to a dairy queen
yeah i mean there's a lot of things
there you know the test i like it um
good luck sean thanks for uh all the
entertainment uh through the years
thank you so much thanks for having me
that's uh
sean white now retired a five-time
olympian three-time olympic gold
medalist